all right what's going on hello welcome
how are you well I need some air
fresheners my boy somebody make fart
okay yeah easy have an explanation
please I wouldn't care I'll explain to
you what happened was serious of I know
terrible right that's Derek right yeah
he was just crouched down under the
table and when he crouches when it like
you know how like give any kids I do you
know you know how when like when a
baby's got gas you fold their legs up
like they're so they're there the gas
gets out a little easier of their AB so
Derek crouched down and he started he
started to and he just [ __ ] it on you
something he did it [ __ ] a hold on Derek
hold on utano over the back of that
exactly it's absolutely what happened I
want we saw we laughed at it man I mean
would you are you thinking about us just
a little bit as your guests and yeah
host up in here man like thank you got a
smell this [ __ ] it wasn't a personal
song as cubical my a nobody man you came
right here some air person of them where
some air fry recent leaving to get air
fresh air ahaha by the way sorry hahaha
Tyrese smells amazing
oh yeah take a walk Derek you got [ __ ]
all over your thighs yeah very much
thank you god damn we needed you a long
time ago Tyree this is a guy who takes a
whole room yes I don't understand it
either
it's ridiculous we don't disagree yeah
we don't need to be in your gas chamber
Derek exactly man yeah I don't want to
get to know you inside out yeah it's
really inappropriate we apologize but
you put on some cologne this morning you
freshen up you don't need me here to
really do my thing right man I came
looking right smelling right right and
he gonna come over and put his ass on
the floor right with this very rude to
the guest yeah ridiculous not
intentionally though that right you guys
dirty hoody on with his [ __ ] all over
his sides yes got nervous little a comic
right before Jason we had Jason Statham
before he just gets nervous when
celebrities coming does not handle it
and it starts far down as it does bro
I know it all right really gross we got
love for you and I just clean it up go
get some baby wipes yeah yeah you know
where you want were you on the set for
when the rocket is Vin Diesel or we're
having their issue - did you see that
happening and just try to avoid it or
did you not see it happening
was you talking about I saw that
Instagram I understand I don't know what
you're talking about I wasn't on the set
I don't know nothing about nothing man I
came here white flag in my hand I went
to media training thank you you really
you really ask the question the right
way that was really good
why you ask it I mean because he did it
only it wasn't something like when
Christian Bale had to say it kind of
sneaks out but in Rock actually put it
out himself
so the must have been something here to
be really mad to put that kind of guy
very likable kind of friendly dude for
him to say that so you must have seen
that on Instagram like what's he talking
about right yeah yeah we all were just
wondering who exactly was he talking
about because he didn't you know if
you're gonna jump out there and get you
bite you know call out names right but
at the end of the day I think there's no
such thing as doing a movie or a TV show
or even a radio show when people got to
be around each other every day and at a
certain point you don't get in your
feelings but it's not supposed to end up
on a time line how do you handle that
you have it you just kind of keep it on
the set if there's ever another look I'm
a I'm a good dude man trying to clean it
up every day so you know the Hollywood
shuffle I don't really play those games
I'll go up in somebody's trailer have
you had to do that of course I and
normally is it just a discussion or is
it a yelling match I mean it's a
conversation it really doesn't get to a
level of yelling in most cases because a
lot of times man folks in Hollywood or
even in music they're not used to people
telling them the truth so once you make
them aware of what they're saying and
doing and how they're making you feel
they sit there looking dumbfounded like
damn I had no idea no one has ever said
that to me so it doesn't really turn
into a shouting match it becomes like
look man we got we got to be on this set
for another seven months when you said
this when you acting like that when
you're coming off this way this is how
it's making me and others feel clean
that [ __ ] up now do you think that they
didn't realize they were doing it or
they're just not used to being called on
it and then it has to
trying to make it about van and when I
say like it and I'm not making it above
I'm really not I'm thinking in general
because you're saying that can sort of
you I'm talking about in general I'm not
talking about doing I'm not either
yeah I'm saying but do you think people
you said that they go I didn't know I
made you feel that way and I'm like do
you think when they say that to you that
they really didn't realize it or they're
so used to getting away with it in
Hollywood they're not getting called on
it well I think I think like I said you
know we deal with a generation of
celebrities and entertainers that are
making so much money and people around
them are making so much money they
create this environment unfortunately
where if you try and tell them the truth
they get all bent out of shape which
means that's that's the key word for
don't tell me the truth or you might
lose your job and when you're making ten
percent twenty percent or you're a
security guard is making three four
thousand dollars a week from doing
security on a set you have some thoughts
and feelings that you want to share to
someone who's being obnoxious or
whatever the case may be but why would I
tell you the truth and compromise my
survival if you want to crash and burn
your own career and I'm making $4,000 a
week if I leave here I got to go make
$100 $200 a week I'm not going to
compromise my money from quote-unquote
keeping it real with you so a lot of
times the truth just don't weed stars
that's a good point my manager I talked
to one time he told me that this network
liked me like they like you I like John
they don't like me they never used me
and he goes but they told me they like
you I'm like but it's to their advantage
to say they like someone there's no
advantage for someone to just go no we
don't like them because then it's
conference just go yeah yeah we like it
when they don't use it I would rather
you say you like me and then tell me a
couple of things that you don't like and
not rob me of the opportunity to clean
it up right like point out a couple of
flooring on it are workable you know you
can say like if they say you know I like
you but I don't like your hair right
they medicine we all know who may trying
to set that you're not you just think in
general right in general yeah right okay
I got you got a great personality you
got a good look to you huh
but I want to change your hair right
then they I don't want you to
not give me they did yes no we are no
longer exchanging I I don't want you to
not give me the gig because you're not
willing to tell me that you want me to
consider a haircut or a different style
right keep it real I like you but I
don't like this okay [ __ ] well now I
have an option to clean it up yeah or to
say [ __ ] you I'm not going to clean it
up but you want the option to object I
mean there's a lot of [ __ ] that I turn
down I never claimed to be the biggest
star but sometime they approached me
about movies your projects and certain
outfits they want me to wear it's never
going to happen but I don't care what
one you know we bring the offer up even
higher I hear you but I'm a man of
integrity and I appreciate that offer I
could use that money it's a nice check
it's a nice opportunity this nice
co-stars but I'm not saying that I'm not
doing it's something that they want you
to say is it something that Marlee you
don't agree with or does it seem cheesy
or what is fee though chi is anything
you know when you got a bunch of guys in
boardrooms writers directors creators
you know there's no such thing as a bad
idea unless you're trying to bring that
idea to a particular person we've all
seen actors and singers sing songs do
music videos and do movies where they're
saying and doing things you like yo what
the [ __ ] were you thinking right kind of
like the recent Pepsi contraflexure doc
talking about it is so it's like at the
end of the day I don't really look at
that and I can't see myself
attacking Pepsi I'm attacking corporate
America they don't have boardrooms with
enough diversity you know if you get out
of the bubble yeah if I wanted to go to
Brooklyn because there's gangs that are
fighting and going to war and I'm from
LA and I got peace treaty intentions
imagine me coming in trying to bring
peace to a city that I'm not from I'll
be smart enough to have conversations
with people that guys booth boots on the
ground real gang guys has been in the
hood that understand the politics and
the sensitivities around what's going on
in the hood so I understand what the
mission is from being in touch with real
advice is coming from people
that actually live here so corporate
America even to this day don't have
diverse board rooms where they can have
someone to step in with an actual voice
that's more in tune with the
sensitivities around what's going on so
basically it's the blindness because we
watch that address our oh how could
anybody think this is poignant or
helpful or meaningful and it's just a
bunch of people would probably do just
have zero zero friends who are just like
them and then they see this this this
will be great attitude their boardrooms
is clearly lacking diversity that's
that's what it boils down to you said
you're a hood guy where are you from
from what Hollow South Central LA so
when you grew up we we like we did you
come to a crossroads like okay I could
go in this direction or I could go in
that direction I mean when you in the
hood man your direction is not
necessarily a priority you know I was
just trying not to die every day you
know like when you got as not all people
in the hood of bad people I'm saying so
you know one day I'm playing basketball
with the homie the next day he's dead
and you're just like he never never was
in a gang never was a bad person never
raped robbed stole anything but he did
so bad things don't just happen to bad
people
in the hood it happens to innocent
people and I was one of them people that
was in the hood every day just trying to
survive and just trying to make it you
know I didn't have a car in my family
there was no daddy and Mama in the house
wholesome environment so you know you're
just trying to survive every day you
know I mean so it's this is the reason
why I feel so blessed to be doing the
things that I'm doing because it all
feels brand-new to me steel because this
has nothing to do with where I'm from
and which was it like a lot of turmoil
growing up and like in the house oh my
god yeah absolutely baby you got my book
on okay oh you have your book you talk
about your your childhood yeah I have my
first book that I've ever released is
called how to get out of you
way right so as most of us are in our
own way but most of us don't know how to
get out of our own way so we a lot of
times we're blocking our own blessings
innately we became our mom or our dads
and don't know it it's like I got a
problem with my childhood and you end up
becoming a duplicate of your childhood
so you know a lot of you know a lot of
us got all the talent in the world and
then we get to a certain point we start
self sabotaging and [ __ ] up our own
opportunities that are right in front of
us and so I wanted to just point out
that because I've worked really hard
every day to basically become better
than my parents become better than the
environment and the choices of the
people in my environment that I grew up
in we starting a self-sabotaging you saw
Katya I was how he doing it I still
self-sabotage at times to this day and
so you just got to work hard at getting
out of your own way and I'm saying so
but a lot of stuff that I was doing
early on I recognized it and I was able
to talk point out the before and after
what self-sabotage for me I'll get like
these negative thoughts and there's also
a comfort in them but they feel I'm used
to them in age you're used to them
because it's probably something that you
witnessed right it's probably there's
someone your father your mom your step
that whatever it may be you witness them
self-sabotage so you find yourself
almost enjoying it or being more
comfortable with the idea of
self-sabotage yeah it's like a feeling
yeah it does it says comfortable yeah
it's almost like a lot of women don't
understand that when men cheat it's not
the idea only of like having sex with
another woman it's the idea that there's
a high of getting away with some [ __ ]
yes Nikki this other scene looking
you're just like and then when a woman
decides to take it away from you then
all of a sudden that ain't fun no more I
mean there are people in open
relationships that's still cheap you
know I mean and that's what it is
because they have to be they want to be
sneaky about it I get that so high yeah
so high so it's self sabotaging could be
there's a bigger better opportunity
in front of you they're trying to put on
the best show ever and something in your
mind says this is going to be more money
this is going to be a bigger platform
it's going to be a bigger opportunity
I'm going to be able to travel I'm going
to this the first form of self-sabotage
is the feeling that I don't deserve it
then the second form of self-sabotage is
you basically creating the most negative
scenarios and outcome outcomes
associated to this amazing opportunity
so then you end up talking yourself out
of some [ __ ] that was supposed to change
your life right become a self-fulfilling
if it gets wrecked and that's what you
do in class yourself that's that's what
I did
right from the beginning based on
patterns and habits that a lot of people
from my community and as well as my
family did and then at times even as an
adult you can still do it
are your parents still are you part
still living and they're still doing
okay or they better work so good they
good I mean you know as you get older
you get kind of an autopilot you know
you're just kind of waking up every day
and then going to sleep and doing the
best you can't kind of chugging along
you know so it just kind of happens now
are you good at someone telling you hey
you're selling if your wife tells you
hate yourself sad are you good at
somebody close to you calling you out or
I mean you know naturally you become
defensive when somebody tells you the
truth and you want to kind of try and
figure out how to justify whatever it is
you're doing or saying but you know my
wife is you know my new wife has gotten
used to me being defensive first and
then she'll automatically see the
adjustment being made which means even
though I fought you on what you said
clearly I agreed with it and I made the
adjustment that's the same exact thing
that I do I can't ever admit like okay
like in the moment you can't say like
you were right right you know what I
mean you're all right I'm going to
change that you're right it's just like
you fight it and then you change it and
then if it comes up again you go I
changed it like that I don't need to
admit it to you if I changed it
well I mean some women just some women
love to hear that they were right right
you know and yeah it's like it's their
own hi-c I was right right and my
husband just confessed to it and it's
like are you trying to help me are you
trying to get that or no place yeah I
tend to like the arguing though it's not
healthy I had a girlfriend one time
stopped me in the noise goes what are
you doing I'm trying to find a solution
and I'm like you're right like I just
love that feeling the pity or stomach of
that that's going back and forth and I
didn't care about being right or wrong I
just wanted to fight it was just well my
question to you becomes are you yelling
at your mama or you yelling at one of
your ex-girlfriends or you yell another
X and they're no longer here so you're
like taking all that [ __ ] out on the
brand-new person that you're with is
that that's sometime happened when you
got some unresolved stuff still
lingering you feel the need to like have
these outbursts that are very angry and
you direct it at the person you're with
and something that they may have did
only only justifies a two percent anger
of level a random anger level but it's
just another put you over the top
you take it to 5,000 and then you like
damn well all you did was forgot to
bring food home that I asked you for but
I'm cursing you out like you've done 12
things instead of just one yeah it
really does there's no like common sense
level of okay this is a - I should
handle like it tails like a - or you
should or you should be willing to
actually have anger or be mad based on
the actual issue and the person that
you're actually with and not have that
to trigger other things from the past
because some of us are just not
conscious of Integris of course is
promoting fate of the Furious as you're
allowed to have an hour
it's always more fun when somebody just
talked about life you know in theaters
next Friday and it's a Tyrese online.com
it's called tyr ESC on on Twitter and
everything I'm telling us we have to rap
with you soon
did you did you arm mouths better in
here that's not that right here so we
appreciate you taking sure we were just
a little too embarrassed for him because
he has a nervous stomach and he said
they nervous
summer all you got to do is go to the
hallway my man yeah they have a lot of
air out there get that [ __ ] out your
system
you can't just fart and then walk back
in it you got a fart and fan he trails
it in you got to just kind of give it
that so that it can leave you a little
bit then walk back yeah it's
embarrassing but yeah I mean it's good
advice
I guess advice from other guys have been
too nervous to mention it we're happy
instead of the scenario away because we
don't like to shame him anymore we got
it well good we do have to wrap it up
but I want y'all to go online right now
and pre-order your tickets on Fandango
com
the fate of the furious is going to be
released worldwide April 14th I know I
was supposed to be talking about the
movie the entire time but look at the
trailer online and we just want to tell
you thank you there's a lot of movies
there's a lot of people out here selling
TV shows and all the above and the fact
that y'all been rocking with us now for
15 years and the diversity of the fans
around the world continue to grow and
show up we do not take it for granted
we stress each other out every day
trying to figure out how can we take the
stakes and the energy and basically the
vibe of this franchise up a notch
and y'all put us under more pressure
than you think because the last one did
1.5 billion so the question is how do we
top that and we just hope we made y'all
proud the box office receipts doesn't
represent just a success it's the fact
that y'all going to show up for so this
Friday April 14 get to a midnight
screening on a Thursday night if you
came and just thank you all in advance
with supporting The Fast and the Furious
and here's I know it's going to be good
because Tyrese is still hungry okay I am
starving right now
perfect my ribs are showing [ __ ]